I love that on you got to work with
Diane Lane where she's the great thing
is marketing for with you as I've said
before she was had a crush on her since
a film she was in Lonesome Dove Laura
darling so I had a crush on her that may
have been was almost preteens for me so
then I get to work with her she looks
about the same as she did back then and
she's one of our great actor actresses
that we have in show business in the
business of storytelling it was a
brillar sigo work with it I said it like
first I said let me get this out right
now I let her know yeah I want you to
take them out on your boat and drop them
in the ocean for the Sharks so I wasn't
filming on an island of course all the
way out in the middle of the Indian
Ocean
yes beautiful this is not one of those
there's no stories of this but oh my god
it was so hard we were so desolated
there's no story this is a beatific
island we Mauritius we did shoot on the
water that has complications but
basically was just gorgeous
yeah where you live was about a
five-minute walk down the beach to the
one set we had so wasn't a rough time
getting war wasn't a rough time walking
home from work every day pretty soon
there's gonna be a new Hollywood Issue
what do you remember from this time and
they knew sex getting to Gracie
I remember that I look like I'm caught
between a smile and swallowing or
something I was like aw he's not your
best shot McConaughey yep that's me no
it's pieces I think that was Leibovitz
who did this and his pieces so you do
three of us three of them three of them
she does these all the time and then
it's a layout where it looks like you're
all there what did that mean for you and
maybe just enough time in your career
well I just finished it some time to
kill so all of a sudden I was fully in
the public eye and I remember it very
clearly you know over a weekend
it went from there's a hundred scripts
I'd love to do but I could only do one
of them to Monday when the movie comes
out was successful all of a sudden I
could do 99 of those and I was like holy
Sh it's three days ago I wanted to do
every single one of these so it was a
it was a fun run a fun ride at that time
it was a lot of new information but I
enjoyed
[Music]